[Music]
oh
p
[Music]
the
oh
[Music]
n
all right let's go ahead and open open
up the doors to daily withd do.com hello
everybody and welcome my name is Becca
dukes and as the hostess of this program
I am excited to be able to bring to you
empowering information instead of the
information that takes away all your
powers and basically tells you you don't
know anything we give you information
that is easy to understand easy to
implement so that you also can find a
better health Journey folks because our
bodies are not chemical deficient
they're nutrient deficient and that's
what you're going to hear on today's
show Daily with Doc now for those of you
who are joining us live if you would
like to ask a question of Dr wallet
because after his opening monologue we
will be having a Q&A session make sure
that you raise your hand so go to that
Zoom menu click on reactions and raise
hand and I will be calling on people in
the order that I see their hands raised
if you are out on any of the different
platforms and watching as a live stream
or even a replay and you would like to
join us you are more than welcome to
join us live Monday through Friday from
12 to 1250 p.m. Pacific Time by going to
daily with. Zoom
.c again that is daily with Doc
zoom.com all together new
spaces the program that you are about to
hear is for educational purposes only
it's not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician the FDA does
require us to let you know and our
products that are mentioned are not
meant to diagnose treat cure any
diseases but folks through the science
of epigenetics it brings us hope that we
actually do have more control over our
health Journey than anyone else wants to
let us be aware of so without any
further Ado if you were invited by this
program by somebody specific make sure
that you get back with them this is a
resource for an amazing community and we
want to make sure that the person that
took the time and cared enough to share
this program with you you has the
opportunity to continue to be every step
of the way on your transformation of
this health Journey now the doctor that
we do have on this program has decades
Decades of not just research but
actually
implementation of what he found through
his research around the world and
starting in the human no starting in the
animal world world he was actually part
of
conservation um strategies to save the
White Rhino and other animals that were
facing poor health conditions and that
wasn't enough for him so he wanted to be
part of Saving the human race as well
and it is my honor and privilege to
introduce to you Dr Joel wallik who has
a Bachelor of Science in agriculture and
plant and soil
Sciences Doctorate of veterinary
medicine with three postdoctorates in
pathology and a naturopathic physician
everybody Welcome Dr Joel wallik hello
Dr wallik welcome well thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you team for uh being
here and and so helpful and and we're
family that's for sure
and uh basically I want to keep moving
forward because we've talked over the
last year I think not quite maybe almost
a year about osteoprosis of the
skull and um there's so many diseases
like
hund there's you
know3 something different diseases
they're caused by osteoprosis of the
skull squeezing the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves and squeezing the cord and
everybody knows that of course here's
the the top pictures of a a normal skull
I got that for you oh thank you in the
bottom picture is that of osteoprosis to
the skull okay and I want you to then
now to go to
page
22 okay got it there you go and now
we're going to talk about osteoprosis of
the verra and arthritis of the of the
disc between the vertebrae because the
disc between the vertebrae are kind of
like the cartilage in your knees and
your hips and that kind of stuff and
it's one of those things where you think
about it okay we've been talking for
almost a year about all these diseases
that are caused by osteoprosis of the
skull and now I kind of moved down a
little bit because the spinal cord is
made in the brain comes out of the back
of the skull goes down to your pelvis
and splits you have the two sciatic
nerves one goes left one goes right but
between the skull and the sciatic nerves
you have all these different nerves
going to the to the heart and the throat
and to the eyes and uh ears um to the
liver to the
intestines um to the lungs it's kind of
amazing now we spend I hope you're all
sitting down uh you've heard me say this
many times before we spend $ 626.
billion dollar a year just to treat
um let's see here osteoprosis to the
skull $26.8 billion a year in America
that's just America alone now let's look
at three communities the United States
Canada and the European Union combined
we spend 6.5 trillion do a year dealing
with osteoprosis
okay of the skull all of the vertebrae
and and of course the disc between
vertebrae and so forth okay women uh
19.6% almost 20% of women have problems
with osteoporosis and Men 4.4% because
men tend to eat bones and bone soup and
bone broth and
they you know they eat tenons and
ligaments and stuff and women don't tend
to do that and so that's why women have
five times the amount of these problems
as men okay because of their diet okay
and so this is kind of interesting when
you look at that page uh 22 to 25 it
goes into all these different diseases
people get you get osteoprosis
of the vertebrae okay and degenerative
disc disease between the vertebrae
because we squeezing all the nerves from
the skull all the way down to your
toes all right most people don't even
realize that
okay and we spend 6.5 trillion with a te
$6.5 trillion each year with these three
communities United States Canada and the
EU European Union to treat just
osteoporosis in
humans just to treat the symptom 6.5
trillion of that 6.5 trillion 2.3
trillion is Americans expenses then you
throw in the 6268 billion for treating
osteoporosis it comes out to three
trillion dollar a year we're spending
for treating the symtoms of osteoporosis
and also the symptoms of arthritis and
osteop process of the skull and so forth
okay this is to me was just driving me
crazy because all you have to do just
like we did for the skull you know you
read that book it's all in the book it's
all in your head okay but the spinal
cord stuff okay is featured in Pages 22
to
27 okay and it's one of those things
where
um this is uh what should I say un
impeachable evidence uh it's preventable
it's
reversible because bones tend to be very
Dynamic and you give bones what they
want they heal very quickly if you don't
give them what they want they fall apart
very quickly okay and so um this is one
of those things where we can save an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
and save everybody a lot of money we can
add many healthful years to their
life and of course in those pages
between 22 and 27 it goes into
everything
that um your um vertebrae your disc
between a vertebrae and all the tendons
and ligaments and your pelvis and all
that kind of stuff down to your leg
bones and and so your arm bones and
sciatic nerves and stuff down to your
toes and fingers they all need these
nutrients to just maintain function and
not have these deficiency diseases but
if you get these deficiency diseases and
you start taking the appropriate
nutrition and and they're listed in
those pages between 22 and 27 it tells
you what to take okay it lays out the
formula I mean you can't go wrong there
it's put it in there for you okay and so
when everybody start thinking okay now
we we got everybody understanding that
we needed to deal with the skull well
now we're adding to the skull the spinal
cord the spinal um skeletal tissues
including the bones and the cartilage
and the ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue and so forth and we
can save an enormous amount of
unnecessary Misery we can save an
enormous amount of money we're going to
add many many Health years to people's
lives by doing this okay it's all in
this little bitty book okay it's all in
your head and I should we probably
should come up with a another title it's
all in your head and your
back oh can't hear you you're muted
you're
muted all right takes me just to their
dog just a moment we could rename it
it's all in your head and butt there you
go
but um so Dr wck tell us a little bit
about what is wallik fibrosis
displasia okay well WX
fibrosis is um is just osteoporosis of
the various bones and joints okay from
the skull all the way down to your
tailbone down to your toe and your
fingertips and so
forth and doctors want everybody to
believe well you're getting old this
just happens because you're getting old
no these are nutritional deficiencies
they're easily prevented and they're
easily reversed and so if you just say
oh osis people say well you're getting
old osteoporosis you got to expect that
no um when you have these things Wallock
dysplasia okay it's repairable within
weeks I don't care if you've had it for
years it's rep within weeks and we have
so many people will call it their
chronic are you all right well yeah I'm
just so happy I you know went back and I
had a MRI of my back and my doctor said
we I've never seen this before but you
had osteoprosis um you know of your
spine for years and you don't have it
anymore and so we're just sort of
shocked
and because the patient did exactly as
the book told them what to do okay and
so I'm so very very excited about this
uh we can save everybody we're right now
we're in 80 countries and so this is
going around the world and we can help
people add many many many Health years
to their to their life and that's why we
call
it wallx fibrosis because it's not
just
um a disease of
Aging okay this is something you're
missing nutrients and that's you're
paying the
price all right and so the porosis Dr
wallik when I think perosis I'm I think
of holes and things not being solid and
and being more
porous so osteoporosis Osteo is bone and
then porous bone yes what happens is the
minerals go away and you're left with
the connective tissue sort of um skellon
inside the bones okay and so we rebuild
the bones on top of that
skeletal we rebuild the skeletal tissue
back on the the connective tissue okay
and which doctors never could figure out
how to do that they said well we just
we're going to amputate your leg and
give you an artificial leg so you won't
have the pain anymore and we won't have
to worry about a fracture okay we'll
just cut your leg off give you an
artificial that was their approach to it
was to give an artificial leg okay we
don't have to do that anymore okay so
we're very very proud of
that and um I'm so so happy that I'm
getting so many calls from people that
you know my doctor said well we're going
to you know
be setting you up to get a leg
replacement and I tell them ask him for
90 days have them give give you 90 days
and you do what I tell you to do and
then when they go in at 30 days and 60
days and 90 days the doctors say well we
don't know why but you don't have
osteoprosis of the spine
anymore you don't have osteoprosis of
the skull anymore you don't have
osteoprosis of your legs anymore
what am I going to do with this
artificial EG that I
bought that's a horrible question Dr W
but I have a really good question and
that's coming from YouTube what are some
of the symptoms that would let us know
that we may have osteoporosis of the
skull of the skull okay well let's just
run down a
few loss of the sense of smell loss of
the vision um
let's see here you get pressure inside
the eye you know glaucoma you get Mac
degeneration which messes up with the
lining in the eye that's cranial nerve
number two cranial nerve number three
tosis the pupil doesn't respond to to
light anymore um cranial nerve number
four double vision okay pain in the eye
cranial nerve number five trial
neuralgia this is one of the biggest
pain things people have is trial
neuralgia okay squeezing the fifth
cranial the skull double vision
stabismus again squeezing the six
cranial nerve uh then you have Bell's
paly one side of the faal droop okay the
seventh cranial nerve is being
squeezed and then
ttis which is sort of like buzzing and
ringing in the ears deafness and vertigo
dizziness if you have all three of those
it's called Minier disease and it was
first diagnosed by dror miner in Europe
okay and that's cranial nerve number
eight cranial nerve number nine loss of
the Gad reflex sense of taste your voice
changes that's the ninth cranial nerve
being squeezed and people say I don't
know I must be getting old my my voice
is
changing well that's because the skull
is squeezing that ninth cranial nerve
okay and then the 10th cranial nerve
gastro I mean this is very painful where
the T cral nerve is squeezing that nerve
going down to your stomach but also you
get hiccups because a branch of that
goes to your diaphragm and also you get
a atrial fibrillation or rapid heart
rate tacky card or slow heart rate
braady cardia it's not the heart it's
the skull squeezing that nerve the tenth
cranial nerve and then the cranial nerve
number 11 a loss of trapezius ability to
raise your hands above your head you I
can't do it anymore okay and then cral
nerve number 12 you get atrophy of the
tongue you lose your sense of taste you
can't swallow so when you have cranial
nerve number nine and 12 being squeeze
you're in trouble okay and doctors want
to cut you open and take your voice box
out and all that kind of stuff and give
you a feeding tube and everything
because you can't swallow food and
everything anymore okay but this is all
easily
reversed okay with just the nutritional
program is laid out in the front part of
the book for the skull and it's from the
middle of the book to the back of the
book
for
osteoporosis of the skull system below
the
skull now Joe has a question Dr wallak
and he wants to know what kind of fiber
builds up in the he says decaying skull
is it connective tissue yeah it's
connective
tissue which just like threads a
connective tissue okay and
um this is what
minerals lay on those threads to make
bone okay it's just like your car tires
you know you have this have the fibers
inside the rubber inside the tires so
you have the maximum strength same
principle
all right thank you so much Dr wallik um
so great introduction I love the fact
that you went over you know the
osteoporosis of the different the parts
of the back too so Ian but if you've got
osteoporosis in your finger or your toe
chances are you've got osteoporosis
breaking down that bone throughout the
whole entire body that's correct higher
up higher up all the way up to the top
folks no osteoporosis of the skull
osteoporosis
period is a nutritional deficiency based
on what you just said that's correct
it's not an aging thing because babies
are born with herbs py which is
osteoporosis um from the neck down in
newborn babies okay they're paralyzed
from the neck down because they have
osteoporosis they're born with because
the mother didn't have all the nutrients
necessary or she was taking them she was
eating gluten and couldn't absorb
them all right well thank you so much
for that Dr Wallock I know there's a lot
of people that are dealing with some of
the symptoms that you read off as you
were going down through the different
cranial nerves and and that's just a
start folks so many other symptoms that
are associated with
osteoporosis yeah I was going to say
digestion respiration because all those
nerves come off off of the spinal cord
have to go between the bones through the
bones the other parts of the body and
when you get osteoprosis
the Bony tissue the connective tissue is
bigger than normal bone and so it
squeezes all those nerves and you get
all this stuff going on in other places
and this is why I always ask people how
many times you wake up at night they go
to the bathroom to urinate once three
times five times it's kind of crazy
I I wake up 10 times a night like once
every hour to go urinate okay and I'm
not drinking all that much water what's
happening there okay that's because the
skull and the spinal cord are squeezing
the
nerves okay they're telling your urinary
ladder to
urinate so the nerves are like the the
highway between the brain and other
parts of the body that then communicates
yeah the target area the target area
yeah all right thank you so much Dr
wallik um folks you probably know
somebody if not yourself dealing with
something that Dr Wall just
mentioned it's a nutritional deficiency
as he mentioned and there are simple
things that we can do
to overcome I mean there's words that I
can't use that you can
but I'm sorry you can repair can
rebuild well tell us what is it Dr
wallik specifically that you would
recommend for somebody who has
osteoporosis
period okay well they need the healthy
brain and heart pack healthy brain and
heart pack and to
that um I would throw
in the let's see here the osto effects I
would also throw in vitamin
D3 um I'm throw in the rebounder sports
drink and they um are they available to
the tissues that need repairing they the
tissues are looking for raw materials
that's why you have pain when you have
osteoprosis
okay and um once you give your body what
it needs the pain goes away and the
bones go back to their normal
size because when you lose the minerals
out of your bones trying to maintain
strength the connective tissue the scar
tissue builds up and so the bones are
thicker okay but they're not stronger
they're actually weaker but they're
bigger diameter than they were when they
had normal bone um
minerals
okay now I know collagen peptides is a
building block for connective tissue is
that something that you would add to it
as well yeah um collagen peptides well
you hear me all the time when I talk to
people that have bone and joint problems
held the brain heart pack excuse me
MSM take three of those twice a day for
100 pounds body weight um take the let's
see here collagen peptides a scoop of
that with the um morning drink and the
evening drink and the collagen peptides
comes from four different species of
animal bones we're talking about fish
poultry um sheep and
beef okay our original just came from
beef only glucogel we made for the ratl
we made the first healthy Bone and Joint
pack for him it was just a Healthy Start
pack with a 90 essential nutrients and
we we we made the glucogel from beef
collagen for him worked for
him worked for me there you go awesome
thank you so much Dr wallik for that and
let's go ahead and start taking some
questions we've got several hands up so
let's go to the first question and
Michael go ahead and unmute
yourself how are you today
sir okay I'm
perfect beautiful what question do you
have for Dr wallik today okay my
question is is not on the um
osteoperosis
prognosis it's it's about um rocell
carcinoma the chromophobe variant um I'm
at I think stage two and the doctors
want to do a radical
nephrectomy with my entire kidney but
I'm in the um I'm under the faith that I
can keep my kidney so what are things
that what are some things I can work on
most importantly to continue to uh keep
my kidney it's functioning perfectly but
I have that tumor on there and I get a
little uh inflammation sometimes like
when I work or when I drink or eat
certain
things okay now is this a is this a
benign noncancerous tumor or is this a
benign
T it's cancerous it's the chromophobe
variant okay well here's here's the deal
Michael when you have cancer any place
it's potentially a life-threatening
issue and if it's in is in one kidney or
both this is the one it's on one kitty
okay
okay you only have in one kidney and so
if you have it in one kidney you want to
pray on that and find out do you just
want to have that one kidney remove
because that the healthy kidney can do
what it needs to do to um give you all
the function of a normal kidney and so
if I were in your position I would go
ahead and remove the one that's
cancerous because it'll be shedding
cancer cells in your bloodstream it'll
be going everywhere in your brain and
your lungs and and you you don't want
want that and so you want to pray on
that decide what you want to do but
again you want your immune system your
immune system makes the white blood
cells and antibodies to go kill and eat
cancer cells and so our immune
system is in the bone marrow and so this
is again where you want the healthy
brain and heart pack um you you look
like a big fellow you weigh what 200 and
something what do you weigh yeah like 2
okay okay 27 almost almost 300
lb okay all right so a minimum you want
two healthy brain and heart packs for
month and finances are not an issue I'd
go with three healthy brain and heart
packs a month if you can get three I
would take a dose of breakfast lunch and
dinner if you can only afford two I
would take a you know a dose of
breakfast and dinner and then you you
want to get a hold of the MSM get two
botes of MSM so you take three of those
at breakfast stre at lunch dinner time
and they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair car ligaments tenons
connective tissue disc between a
vertebrae bone makes bone itself okay
and um uh but it also fixes the bone
marrow which is what makes your white
blood cells your antibodies which is
your defenses against cancer okay okay
okay so you want to do that so you want
your defenses against cancer and then
pray on it get other opinions and find
out if what they think about removing
that one kidney with the cancer in it
and leaving the healthy kidney in okay
um the good lord gave us two kidneys for
a reason and of course just like you
have two legs and two arms two eyes and
so you have a a pair and a spare kind of
thing going on and so you you know you
just have to think okay um am I just
going to risk a couple of those cells
breaking loose out of this cancerous
kidney and going into my brain then what
are you going to do okay and so um I I
would pray on that and talk to other uh
people okay speak to other doctors and
get other opinions and make your
decision which way you're going to go
okay then let us know and and you know
we can all pray with you and for you
okay okay thank you thank you you're
very welcome sir keep us
informed I
will thank you Michael and Dr
wallik would you recommend adding in the
fucoid Z or the Z radical know that
fucoidin has a lot of studies that
relate to the
CW yeah and yeah anything that raises
your immune system that helps your
immune system and of course um the
fucoid Z liquid we have the um all kinds
of stuff you know make the make your
bones healthy and happy uh especially
the bone
marrow and um this is where the
collagen and the collagen peptides do
that all right thank you so much Dr
W
so now my next question Dr wallik is
coming from Eric out on YouTube Eric
wants to know how do you deal with H
pylori and
ulcers so Eric's uh 29 years old 5
foot6 uh 75 kilograms that's what just
under 150 pounds
or just over a little more just a little
more than 150 PBS
okay okay 150 PBS okay and and so let's
see here he's got
uh H pylori okay he's got stomach ulcers
right got osteoprosis to the skull okay
squeezing that tense cranial nerve that
vagus nerve
okay can be causing terrible pain in the
stomach so there's so Dr W if they've
ran tests and they've confirmed that
there is H pylor
present yeah well h p this is what cidal
silver is for cidal silver will kill all
bacteria fungus yeast and so forth
including h
pyer C Silver four doses a
day okay okay there's no alcohol in it
so it doesn't burn if there's an open
wound
someplace all right thank you so much
for that Dr
wallik and let's go to the next hand
that is
up and Kathy go ahead and unmute
yourself hi hi how we help hi want to
know um I have a friend and she she had
bad she had bad
diarrhea even even when she don't eat a
lot of food so what would you
recommend okay how old is she what is
she
weigh she about 60 years old she weigh
about 125
pound okay um are you close to her do
you know that she you know waking up
five times a night to go to the bathroom
or anything like that
no I don't know that okay yeah you might
ask her um yeah if she has diarrhea um
she could be eating gluten or buckwheat
that can be causing diarrhea because
they lose those V those little finger
like projections in your intestine to
help you absorb nutrition got to get rid
of wheat Bown IR oats no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no gluten no
wheat B IR oats no buckwheat no sugar no
carbonat drinks you the diet drinks got
to go and carbonated water's got to go
because they neutralize stomach acid so
you cannot absorb metals or Digest food
she needs to get a hold of the Dr Al
cooking without the bad foods 300 pages
of safe recipes and cooking it also has
a good food bad food list in there Dr
cooking about the bad foods and then
also uh let's see here at 125 pounds I
wanted to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month a half of those
twice a day one bottle of MSM so you can
take three breakfast for your dinner
time again that's going to help U
rebuild the the um bone Mar for white
blood cells and um that sort of thing to
help with the defenses okay but also um
you want absorption okay so you got to
get rid of all that bad foods and then
don't forget the ultimate enzymes take
the ultimate enzymes two or three of
those before each meal um that will help
there and let's see here I
think um that's where we want to start
okay thank you you bet all right thank
you Kathy and Dr wellik I have a
question that's coming in off of
Facebook um we have a 73y old
male um let see weight is 76
kilograms he has a benign prosthetic
hyperplasia and kidney stones so he is
on some Pharmaceuticals for the kid KY
Stones um and also a pharmaceutical for
prostate and he gets frequent urinary
infections
okay and it could be since you waking up
at night maybe three five eight 10 times
and doctors are just interpreting that
as a prostate issue U we see the same
thing in women okay women don't have
prostates but you know they're going to
blame it on the prostate because they
can do surgery and you know make a
little bit of money for their kids
tuition to school okay but at any rate
um let's see here need
to kidney stones are caused by as
Calcium deficiency doctors get it all
wrong they say oh you got to stop taking
calcium no kidney stones are caused by
deficiency of calcium and so your body's
pulling calcium out of your bones and if
it pulls too much out it'll precipitate
into your kid as a kidney stone okay so
kidney stones are a signal that you have
a kidney excuse that you have a
deficiency of calcium in your diet and
your body's pulling the calcium out of
your bones trying to maintain proper
blood levels of calcium and that's
what's happening here okay
and you want to uh get somebody else to
kind of look at an MRI or something like
that the prostate
um and see what's going on there you
know is is the prostate really got
something wrong with it or are they just
thinking there's something wrong with it
because there's kidney stones and you
know who
knows all right thank you so much Dr
wallik and did you give the full
protocol for that well yeah the need
them let's see here 150 pounds two
healthy brain and heart Pat month full
twice a day two Botts a month to the MSM
take three breakfast three at lunch at
dinner time um one scoop twice a day day
of the collagen peptides one scoop of
the morning drink one scoop of the
evening drink okay and don't forget the
rebound or sports drink it's another
source of minerals okay going to raise a
source of minerals and that'll stop
pulling minerals out of the
bones all
righty all right thank you so much Dr
wck and let's go to the next T that is
up and John go ahead and unmute
yourself hi John how are
you let's try one more time there you go
am I unmuted yep yes you are oh okay
I've got a something over my face I
can't see myself but if you can see me
that's great um yes um I actually sent
in um a an email or whatever you call it
a little earlier so I'm not going to go
there just right now but um I had a uh a
surfing accident several years ago and
um I jammed my neck really hard and
fortunately I didn't break it I mean
with the incident that took place I
could have been quadriplegic so I am
blessed that that did not happen but uh
the the thing that concerns me is uh I
had an x-ray recently that showed a
couple of vertebrae in my neck that
appeared to be
fusing is that something that is
reversible of course um when just were
you here on the beginning of our show
today uh yeah I heard some of it that's
one of the reasons I raised this
question yeah because um the vertebrae
are separated by the disc correct okay
which are sort of like soft cartilage
that might have in your hips and your
knees and your fingers and shoulders and
that kind of stuff
okay and so it's one of those things
where uh you want to
um okay kind of think like a teenager
get a hold of my book dr's cooking
without the bad foods 300 pages of safe
recipes has a good food bad food list in
there Dr is cooking without the bad
foods and then how much you weigh sir
well I I started on the 2.5 about uh two
months ago and I weighed
194 I weit this morning at
171 okay so you're 171 now okay right so
all right so want to get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no gluten no wheat no
baros no buckwheat no sugar no
carbonated drinks the diet drinks got to
go and also the carbonated water got to
go they neutralize stomach acid so you
cannot absorb nutrition or digest
food and then um you want two healthy
brain and heart passion month full twice
a day two bottles a month of the msms
you take three at breakfast three at
lunch at dinner time and they're going
to support and promote meain repair of
cartilage ligaments tenons connective
tissue disc with vertebrate bone Mak
bone everything from the skull down your
spine hips Shoulders Knees elbows
fingers toes all that will regrow okay
as long as you're alive I don't care if
you're 120 you can regrow joints and
bones okay so does that mean I have to
give up ice cream
nope no it does not because you know if
if if Dr wallik had to give up his ice
cream he would be an cranky old
man not cranky old man so no you just
have to read labels and you're G to find
that there are more and more options
when it comes to
gluten-free on the market when it comes
to even ice cream yep gluten-free ice
cream absolutely
all right thank you you bet keep in
touch call us every couple weeks let us
know how it's going yep thank you John
and I did receive your question I'm
gonna be responding to that okay so all
right well Dr wck let's move right over
to Cindy Cindy go ahead and unmute
yourself uh you unmuted for a moment
unmute yourself please there you go can
you hear me yes okay my sound went down
really low but it was just about
everything you said Dr Wally I was just
wondering with the lymphatic system
because a lot of people when they go to
the doctor they just want to lay down
and stay there after taking um some of
those drugs I know we have to get up and
move to get the lymphatic system going
so when there are older people um you
know like over 50 or 60 I guess just
walking and working in the garden is
that just kind of good to add to
everything else that we're doing yeah
exercise you know a reasonable level of
exercise is a good thing for helping to
circulate blood and lymph and all that
kind of stuff um and so um but you need
more you need nutrition okay you need
more than just exercise you need to
avoid the bad stuff okay again but
exercise is a good thing you can overdo
it you know you do anything you over do
drinking too much water okay I mean so
you have to put everything in Balance um
you know weigh yourself every couple of
days or every day depending on you know
come in the house and jump on the scale
before you take your shower after you've
done your exercise kind of
thing and and um it doesn't hurt once a
year to get a hair analysis get a hold
of that book uh rare Ur cures go to
chapter 1011 page 272 tells you how to
collect the hair or to ship it because
you can't get this information from a
blood test goes into all the levels of
the nutritional minerals as well as all
the levels of the bad toxic minerals you
know like lead and mercury and uranium
and that kind of stuff and so uh you
know we have to participate in our own
defense you can't wait until you have
some clinical thing going on something
really bad you go to the doctor oh we
got to put you in the hospital and run a
bunch of tests and then you get killed
with one of the test okay yes and so um
you want to be doing as many of these
things as you can yourself and if you're
doing the young jity business as a
business um in your business plan um you
put in there that your business will pay
for uh your health care including your
um maintenance and health test and
supplement program and so forth and so
it's a win-win-win situation if you do
everything correctly and participate in
your own Health don't just say well I go
see the doctor every year well that's
not good enough okay
right and thank you Dr wallik for
helping us to be more aware of the Blue
Zone and the green zone we we're
bringing that back thank
you all right thank your coaches so yes
thank you thank you thank you Cindy and
Dr well I have some questions coming in
from YouTube and Facebook and the
question that I have from YouTube is
coming from penny so penny is 69 years
old 5 foot n 210 pounds she's taken the
90 essential um or 90 for life for a few
years now she's almost gluten-free um
but her thinking is still not clear and
sharp uh Vision was not what it was
reading is no longer enjoyable she has
arthritis cervical lum bar stenosis
moderate gird
um stress but I can't read what what's
under the rest of word okay so she's
wanting to know what would be a protocol
that you could recommend for her that's
also going to help to clear up and make
her thinking sharp again okay well she's
get rid all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meat no oils no glutens no
wheat butter R oats no buckwheat no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
ones got to go and carbonated water got
to go then I want her to get that book
Dr L cooking about the bad foods 300
pages of safe recipes and cooking
methods and so forth don't it also has
the good food bad food list in that book
Dr cooking about the bad
foods then at 210 pounds I wanted to
have two healthy brain and heart packs
per month the full do s twice a day she
eats two bottles a month of the MSM so
she could take three at breakfast three
at lunch at dinner time they're going to
support and promote main repair of
carart ligaments tenons connective
tissue disc between vertebrae bone B
cell as well as the bone marrow to make
white blood cells and antibodies and red
blood cells and platelets and all that
kind of stuff um let's see here and then
when you're talking about um sharp
thinking sharp Vision all that kind of
stuff again we have utive uh take a
couple two or three of those twice a day
in addition to your 90 essential
nutrients take the healthy brain and
heart pack a full do of that twice a day
um the MSM we already talked about uh
the collagen peptides scuba that with
the morning drink scuba out the evening
drink don't forget the the rebound or
sports drink you have one or two of
those um a day at you know at 218 pounds
or 210 pounds can't every one right in
here um it's one of those things where
having at least one rebound would be
good a day because you're getting
another 100 nutrients by doing that
okay and the sharp Vision the utive
three of those twice a day
Vision FX three those twice a day and
the gird has to do with um it could be
the stomach okay reacting to the diet or
it could be the stomach reacting to the
skull being squeezed and are the spinal
column being squeezed okay from
osteoporosis and so you have to deal
with all that okay all right thank you
so much for that Dr wallik and the next
question is coming from Rebecca out on
Facebook she says her Cy is going
through chemo for breast cancer they say
that she's anemic and white blood count
is high she's
dehydrated
and wants to know what supplements that
she could be taking so let's go by 100
pounds Dr wck okay go by 100 pounds okay
well get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no gluten no wheat rhos no buckwheat no
sugar no carbonat drinks even the D
drinks and the carbonated water got to
go and then per 100 pounds of body
weight I would have her take one healthy
brain and heart pack per month if she
only weighs 110 pounds it' be half a
dose of breakfast half a dose of dinner
times if she weighs 140 150 pounds or
more she needs two healthy brain and
heart packs a month to full those twice
a day then she
needs let's see here I'd also have her
take the MSM take three of those the
breakfast lunch and dinner that' be two
bottles a month and that will support um
maintenance repair of cartilage liament
tenons connective tissue including the
bone marrow where your white blood cells
and antibodies are made which goes after
and kills cancer cells okay so that's
important to make your bone marrow happy
okay and let's see here
um um I I would also use the rebound or
sport strength she she should also use
the sport strength
and uh so let's go there it wouldn't
hurt to do a hair analysis to see if she
has any toxic Metals in her you cannot
tell from a blood test again um the book
rare Urban cures chapter 10 um and 11
start at page 272 tells you how to
collect the hair how to package it or to
ship it don't forget to put the check in
there because the lab won't run the test
without it and then just you know follow
what needs to be done based on the
results
okay all right thanks do you have time
for one more if it's a quickie okay AJ
do you got a quick
one go ahead and unmute
yourself hello doc
uh uh Cedric out on YouTube wants to
know what we would do about uh getting
attempting to get off of
dialysis okay um somebody's on dialysis
you know they need to give it all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat no
notes no buckwheat no sugar no carbon
drinks even the diet ones got to go and
carbonated water got to go and then per
100 pounds of body weight they need one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
if they only weigh 100 pounds be a half
of those twice a day if they weigh 135
140 pounds or more be full those twice a
day again um
the I'd go with the um excuse me um
let's see here
the did you say ultimate daily Classic
Dog yeah celc disease is that right is
that what it said no kidney off they
were wanting to get off dialysis oh
dialysis that's right thank you dialysis
um yeah dialysis need the ultimate daily
classic tablets ultimate daily classic
tablets three twice a day that's two
bottles a month they're small bottles
and it will um make the k work better
okay and we take people that haven't
urinated in 10 years and their own
dialysis six days a week we put them on
this program we just laid out okay with
a healthy um let's see here healthy um
start pack okay brain and heart brain
brain and heart pack yeah but they also
need the um the they they need the
um sweeties huh and any sweet EAS
involved with blood sugar or no no this
isn't blood sugar this is this is um has
to do with with kidney function okay so
we need the Beyond Osteo FX Beyond osto
FX three of those at breakfast three at
dinner time that'll be two b a month
that's going to and so this um one
person again was on dialysis six days a
week for 10 for 10 years hadn't urinated
in 10 years and two weeks time they're
urinating so they dropped the diis down
to three days a week and then two more
weeks are totally totally normal and so
they took them off dialysis completely
okay so even even if you're really
really in trouble with your kidneys your
kidneys can heal and function and go
back to working if you give it
everything it needs okay and we don't
want to forget that ultimate daily
classic as it promotes circulation of
the blood through even the kidneys
that's
correct all right thank you so much yeah
the kidneys are the one that deal with
the blood pressure okay blood pressure
and so
um and the kidneys if it's not happy
it'll release hormones and make the
blood pressure go
up so again it's not a heart
issue okay I gotta run kiddo thank you
so much Dr wallik for joining us here on
daily with Doc folks you've been
listening to almost an hour of
empowering information that is allowing
you to able to make choices based on uh
the research not just what was found or
what they think is going to chemically
mask a symptom but actually looking at
the nutritional deficiencies that were
found through autopsy when a disease
occurred so that to me I think is more
important than ever looking
at
okay what's going to stop this
symptom no what started the symptom
folks let's look at that let's go deeper
and when you give your body what is
designed to have from the beginning
you're going to eliminate a lot of pain
and and distress and discomfort and all
those awful things later in
life and it's not too late so I'm very
thankful that it was not too late for me
if I could have my co-hosts on the
screen with me that would be much
appreciated folks this program is being
sponsored by daily with Doc I have a
team of amazing coaches and these are
just a few of them who help us bring
this information to you free of charge
now of course what Dr wallik is
recommending is not free it's an
investment into you your health yourself
your family family and whenever you take
a look at what you're eating and
eliminate the things that have actually
caused or contributed to poor health
conditions and then add in the nutrients
that the body has been starving for the
body can do some amazing things we've
all experienced the benefits of what the
body can do when we follow Dr Wall's
recommendations and we are inviting you
to do the same I am so thankful for my
executive production manager Ruth Ellen
Sanchez who helps keep us organized and
make sure everything is in there the
assistant to the executive production
manager AJ who helps us make sure that
we've got everything streaming where we
can stream and making sure that we're
meeting people where we're at as you
know technology is absolutely fabulous
and as we uh discover that technology
always doesn't work the way we want it
to when we want it to work AJ is my
right hand when it comes to figuring it
out and making it happen so thank you AJ
for that and for Marilyn who is
dictating everything that Dr wallik is
mentioning as protocols and
recommendations for people in the show
she is putting that into typed text here
in the zoom room which is one of the
greatest benefits of being here live
with us Monday through Friday from 12:
to 12: 50m Pacific time at Daily withd
zoom.com and we have Albert who is
joining us on the road and and that's
something that I think is pretty
spectacular folks no matter where we're
at as long as we have internet
connection we can plug in and do our
part in helping a greater community so
thank you so much Albert from joining us
somewhere in South Africa today on in
your travels um and it's actually
nighttime for him folks middle of the
night in fact and we just appreciate
your dedication and that's one thing
that I absolutely love about the people
that are within our youngevity family
they believe in something so much that
they have that dedication to make sure
that people are getting the information
that they can then Implement in their
own lives to benefit them not just the
here and now but in the future as well
if you have a desire to be part of
something like this please get back with
the person that shared this program with
you also get back with them if you have
a condition that you would like to have
all a more natural approach to in using
nutrition get back with the person that
shared this program with you if there is
nobody to thank I do have my amazing
team we can be reached at 855
that's 855
3377 you can also go to our website and
on our website we have the contact
option and that will send us an email
don't forget to sign up for our
newsletter with our newsletter we're not
going to spam you with a whole bunch of
stuff we will send to you weekly
previous week's shows with descriptions
and quick links so that you can review
and share with other people we also have
a newsletter that is getting ready to
start that's going to give you more
information that helps you see within
the body and how those nutrients really
do help to support it so I just want to
make sure that everybody is not missing
out and if you are sharing this program
we'd like to thank you so make sure that
you are signed up and registered for our
giveaway at d PWD giveaway.com where as
you are sharing you can earn points and
thank you gifts from me and the team so
everybody thank you again so much for
joining us my name is Becca dukes and as
the leader of this team and also the
director of student services for The
Institute of holistic health we invite
you to make an impact in your own health
and in the health of those you know in
love because together as we are working
as individuals we can reach around the
world for a healthier happier World till
next time bye for
[Music]
now
la
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
go